rock and roll it really is a magical
thing
this is it it's not just any hall of
fame it's the rock and roll hall
of fame
[Applause]
make some noise for my man l cool j i
want to thank all of you
the go-go's beauty and the beat blew the
doors of my life off we love you and you
will always be in our heart it's just
unbelievable
carol king is the greatest songwriter of
all time she's inspired us all so much
oh thank you thank you
being black in america not as easy as it
looks
[Applause]
i went to every single record company
and you know what they said right that
is trash
i for not one second changed my course
now that's rock and roll
tina turner is who we're here tonight to
celebrate
[Music]
[Applause]
food fighters this band is one of the
greatest rock and roll bands thank you
all very much for hanging out with us
[Applause]
[Music]
you